[موسيقى]
رئيس عرفه وعلامه سنوات وهو رجل
تكوينه عسكري وهو جنرال في الجيش وهو مسيس
وكان وزير الاول وليس جمهوريه منتخب مهما
قيل في الانتخابات
وبالتالي
وكل ما نعرفه انه هرب كما قيل يعني ليست
لدينا اي معلومات عن كيف خرج هل كان ذلك
عنوه
هل وقعت خيانه هل هنالك شيء من هذا القلب
عليه عريفه جيدا في في قلب الازمه
ويغادر او كما يقولوا بعض ناس يعني يخلق
المكان
[موسيقى]
ماذا قصد الرئيس التونسي الاسبق زين
العابدين بن علي عندما نقل اليك عبر صديقه
لانه غدر عنوه اذا صاحب التعبير بانه لم
يخطر ان يغادر بنفسه هل اجبر على ذلك اذا
استعمل انه لم يغادر من تلقائي نفسه انه
لم
يتخذ القرار الذي كيف غادر الله اعلم
روايه ليست امامي مدعمتها الحقيقي
اتهم الجميع في ذلك كل من كان له صله
بالشان الامني والامن الرئاسي الى اخره
اتهموه واتهموا بعضهم البعض ولذلك لا يمكن
ان نقول ان فلانا او فلتانه
[موسيقى]